[Music]
did you guys
see or hear technically uh the melania
trump's secret recording where
supposedly it's supposed to make her
seem really like
so juicy bombshell i listened to it and
i didn't understand
what was happening you didn't hear the
bombshell what was
what was the scandal it's a huge scandal
i haven't heard i don't know
officially waging war against christmas
okay i don't know if i'm just stupid
but it sounded like she was just
complaining about how
she has to do the white house christmas
party thingy
and then she's also complaining about
like
like the whole daca not daca but the um
the immigrant kids
that are caught up in the thing to begin
here
it's so melania's ex-friend
and she also was one of the advisors
like her advisor
she secretly recorded melania back in
2018 what kind of friend is that
sounds like a [ __ ] to me hey y'all
right
who does that i think he's calling
everybody a [ __ ] today yeah yeah
like i'm like your best friend right and
then like i'm recording the phone
call for what purpose to use later
you've already decided you're doing it
that's not a friend that's a foe
that is a scheming ass [ __ ] and she
shouldn't be called as
melania's friend so her name is
stephanie winston
wolcoff and she was a senior advisor
for the east wing and so she
says that she started recording after
she had already been accused
of some [ __ ] and so this was her way of
like protecting herself
is what she's claiming okay accused from
who
so she was accused of of pocketing money
from them so from the inauguration so
she
her firm was paid more than 26 million
dollars most
most of which went to subcontractors but
1.6 million of that went directly to her
business
and on top of that she personally
received 500 000
for her role in the inauguration she was
already going through some [ __ ] she had
already left the white house
when she had recorded this so that's
the reasoning as to why she recorded it
she also came out with a book
called melania prize surprise where she
details her relationship her friendship
with her
and like her the falling out books make
money though you know biden made a
[ __ ] ton of money from his book obama
after his presidents dreams from my
father and michelle obama
they made a ton i think biden made his
biggest fortune
after becoming a vice president um
you know with this book and then touring
with the book same with obama though i
think it's a good it's a good
it's a good business so she came out
with a book
monica lewinsky probably made a ton how
i sucked clinton's dick that's what she
called it it was a good title
yes it was finally somebody just titled
it what it was clinton balls
oh it's called clinton come because of
the dress was
yeah remember she she framed her dress
and she was like i
you see the clinton come that was odd
i wasn't i was i was a child when that
happened so i didn't really
fully understand it all but i was like
why would she have a dress with [ __ ] on
it well well now that you're an adult
you get it though
yeah she's framing it she's like this is
present do we get it that's the
presidential campaign
the whole thing again no so that's yeah
that's like quality high quality
comments right there
so she intentionally saved it she was
giving a blow job and then he busted on
her like dress and stuff
and then like she's like see exhibit a
presidential calm you know what people
forget about this actually it's in this
kind of star report she was also
diddling his butt with her tongue really
i'm not kidding
diddling her the wording it's your rim
job brother
it says anal population or some [ __ ] no
that's not fun that like didn't
simulation is tongue
that's what that's you know clinton is a
next level dude the idea is that she was
tongue in his butthole too
and that was left out of a lot of the
reporters in the oval office like for
sure
yeah while he's on the phone with a
[ __ ] ambassador
hell yeah was sick that's so sick that's
nasty that means he didn't take a shower
he's the president how was it discovered
like that part i never understood they
interviewed
everybody they interviewed her and so
they just wrote everything the [ __ ] down
but it's kind of creepy but like how did
it come to life did everyone was like
yeah
she gave him a [ __ ] that came to
light but the the other part is in the
transcript you have to read the [ __ ]
song
no i mean like just the the plain simple
fact that she gave him
a blow job who how like how did it so
okay so linda tripp was
a clinton she worked in the west wing
she uh was confided in by monica
lewinsky
who she told linda tripp that i've been
sucking clinton's dick
because everyone kind of knew already
because she was just couldn't help and
she was in the west wing a lot and she
was like around him a lot and in his
orbit a lot and so it's kind of like
come on
and then secret service new and all that
kind of [ __ ] so secret service probably
knows
everything because they keep secrets
i've talked about this before my uncle
is a white house photographer he
had clinton go up to him one time and
say
hey that trick's pretty cute can you get
her number he was wearing a black suit
because it was like a black tie event
and and he was a he was an associated
press photographer so he thought he was
secret service he thinks you could
service and then my uncle's just like
oh i'm all right i'm on camera like i'm
not secret service
and then clinton just like walked away
but yeah i mean everyone knew clinton
was squeezing on chicks
why is it a mystery that clinton isn't i
mean why do people go
oh my god clinton is so [ __ ] not very
presidential especially in the 90s no no
the point is like
now why do people get shocked when they
hear like clinton is a dirty dog well
the idea
the idea behind it was that because
everyone
like they like to go it was just a
[ __ ] right but the idea was that he
had been accused of sexual assault by
many women
and this provides more credibility to
their claims
because he has been caught doing
something like similar
with somebody else even though it was
not it was it was he was a sexual
predator but he was using his position
of power obviously to get monica
lewinsky to do this
he was like buddy buddy with jeffrey
epstein with me just because he plays a
saxophone and he was on the simpsons
everyone thinks he's all cool and [ __ ]
but he was a [ __ ] harvey weinstein
his voice was really like rico do you
think it's because he was
cooler than harvey weinstein and not as
ugly people accepted him
of course he's cooler than [ __ ] yeah so
it's kind of like oh he's just a player
and when you look at harvey weinstein
you're like that guy's disgusting
ugh right so he looks like a gross
[ __ ] nasty sexual predator
whereas like clinton is a sexual
predator but then people are kind of
looking at him like oh that's good old
bill
has hillary ever spoken about this yeah
what did she say she wrote a book about
it and she's about that
was it isn't it like a stand by him
thing she did afterwards she did the
stand by your man thing yeah okay okay
anyway let's talk about melania here so
uh the [ __ ] powerful women have to deal
with though
right isn't that crazy when you have to
threaten and intimidate all these people
who
who have accused your husband of
horrible things that's terrible i'm
gonna play
the son like a portion of the audio
clips that i got leaked
or not leaked she she went on to cnn
to expose this here we go
i'm completed i'm the same like him i
support him i don't say enough i don't
do enough
100 you have no choice bombshell okay
and then i do it and i said that i'm
working on christmas
planning for the christmas and they said
oh what about the children that they
were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom i
i didn't have a chance needs to go
through the process and through the law
but here's my thing hear what you just
said but instead of that
if if you just your messaging
you you were so loved you would not do
the story
we put it out they would not do the
story
until you would not believe it they
would not does this make her look good
because exactly that's because the story
because
they are they are against us media
yeah if i go but it's all liberal media
i don't want to go to [ __ ] class me
and tiff this morning we're talking
about it we're like
what if this is like a a double mind
[ __ ] like not a double like a mind [ __ ]
like reverse
psychology what if she was sent to cnn
by melania and trump because just spread
like whatever news like i don't even
know what the [ __ ] they're even talking
about here
yeah because i'm on show this is what i
this is what i get from that clip
okay uh because i was confused too
because there was a lot of things going
on but now what i get from this clip
is uh i don't want to do like well i
have to [ __ ] do these
presidential wife duties of christmas
parties and [ __ ] and then no one cares
about it right no one cares about and
then they scrutinize me
because i'm not doing important [ __ ]
like saving the kids from the family
and then she follows up with we tried to
we tried to reunite them and they
wouldn't air it the liberal media yeah
that makes her look good because it's
like they did it was like where were
they when obama did that which is when
that whole program
started it started during obama that's
what blows my mind is
why does why does the uh this camp get
in trouble
for all of this when it was obama that
did it all so the obama one
according to cnn in this article which
is from cnn they're saying that
when it was obama doing this
children were separated from their
parents only when authorities had
concerns for their well-being or could
not confirm that the adult was in fact
their legal guardian
but apparently under under trump it's a
blanket policy like no matter what they
get separated what was what was everyone
pissed about though they were pissed
about the photos
and the photos were taken when obama was
president that's what everyone was
running with like in
every newspaper the photos that were
photos of the kids in the cages
that was during obama that didn't happen
during trump and so everyone was pissed
about that yes there was a change in
enforcement
that happened when trump became
president but he was basically saying i
have to enforce this
law obama wasn't enforcing the law
that's how screwed up politics is
it's emotional it's all about emotions
man everyone if you can just make an
emotional connection with somebody and
make them think
that trump put the kids in the cages
obama didn't want them in the cages even
though they were literally there
because it follows the narrative of
trump hates mexicans
right when he was really talking about
ms-13 not mexicans
salvadorians he was talking about the
gang because okay
trump get her right salvadorian so the
thing is the journalist asked him
about ms-13 the gang right and then so
when he responded he was talking about
yeah they don't bring the best people
out here they bring
you know rapist killers and murderers
well he also said they
and some i assume are good people
afterward which they always cut off on
shows like that right so then
that they took that clip and then they
framed it where they're
he's talking about he hates mexicans i
thought the same thing too until i
watched the whole thing and i
and i saw that the journalist was asking
about what are you gonna do about ms-13
and then the gang problem
and i was like holy crap now all of us
think
that he just hates mexicans
and then if you see this it looks like
oh [ __ ] he threw mexican kids
in cages if you want the ultimate mind
[ __ ] look up the charlottesville video
that everyone talks about all the time
where they say he talked about
good people on both sides if you look
like two sentences down he says i'm not
talking about the white supremacists
of the white nationalists they should be
totally condemned it's in the same
[ __ ] i never heard that part because
the news didn't show it
on purpose yeah but why then in the
debate he hadn't
he had a chance because he's so stupid
that's why why did he not do that we all
know that he had a chance to clear it up
right as far as i'm concerned he could
still be a race a week
a week prior to that he declared the kkk
a terrorist organization
uh in congress right so that's what's so
wild about this [ __ ] is like
yeah he is so stupid he can't even
communicate his own policy he did a
[ __ ] week prior
like i honestly believe that he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and he can't articulate at all but what
blows my mind is how the media
manipulates all of this
so much to the point where it's like
holy crap like
they're just lying outright if they were
like yo here's where trump is [ __ ] up
and they just reported
real [ __ ] and not this [ __ ] where
they give you
something that is taken out of context
or his lies we would all be better off
because then more of us would trust the
media right now media
trust i don't trust it at all in the
toilet because of [ __ ] like this do you
have any like media sources that you
feel is like the most trustworthy
i like the hill but dude you have to
really pick and choose like
like when you're reading all this [ __ ]
you just have to because okay for
example and i was just saying this to a
buddy the other day remember
when um the media hates trump 24 7 365
right
but the day that the media gave trump
credit was when he bombed that site the
missile site
in i think was syria right he he bombed
this place and then everyone on every
channel said the same thing
they all said this is the night when
trump became president it's like creepy
it's like wait so when he's warmongering
that's when you guys give him credit but
when he wants to pull troops out
that's when you guys take the biggest
shits on him and say all the generals
don't trust him and all this kind of
[ __ ]
so that's what scares me as i know
raytheon all those guys the big defense
contractors they're in charge
trump calls it out but he's still owned
by them still gets military budgets
approved
for them so it's the weirdest [ __ ]
mixed messaging
ever sure i think i think bottom line is
if you want the real news
you have to go back story and backstory
and backstory and backstory and
understand all the different avenues and
backstories to understand what the
current situation is
which most people don't have the time or
for me i don't even have the capacity to
understand everything to its fullest
extent like joe was saying
but you go mainstream though mainstream
it's all emotional and it's easy to
understand emotion you know and i think
that's the kind of
discrepancy here i thought he blatantly
was saying
mexicans come in and they're rapists
exactly what it sounded like that's what
i thought too
right and then like i was reading and
people were like no watch the whole
thing watch the whole thing and then i
watched the whole thing and then it
started with the journalists saying like
and then they were talking about
ms-13 the gang back and forth and it
went and then i saw the whole
whole part and i was like oh [ __ ] and
then is that why after
he said that he came out with his
[ __ ] taco tuesday the taco bell
photo it's like right mexicans right the
best
the best but anyway back to this melania
thing
so it's just really interesting because
i i
i heard the whole thing with anderson
cooper and
the interview that she did which i was
going to play you guys a clip but now
conspiracy yo
but like the entire time though i'm like
so this is supposed to make it look bad
i don't get it
like where is the bad like the really
bad it makes her look really human
is what it does i don't know i was
confused and then also the best friend
the stephanie
or the the former friend her being
interviewed by anderson
if you listen to what she's saying she's
backing her up
the whole time what makes her sound bad
though is is
talking about kids in cages and then
being like what the [ __ ] i gotta do this
christmas [ __ ] it sucks like that's what
i think makes her sound better well i
feel like
i mean from the way i under understood
it it was kind of like
why am i doing like you guys have me
doing this christmas [ __ ] that i'm
forced to do and fine i'm [ __ ] doing
it and as i'm doing this [ __ ] that i
don't even
like no one cares about and then you're
asking me this stuff like why aren't you
doing anything about the kids
when i did go to the border and no other
first lady has gone to the border and i
did
and they changed the policy and then
they yeah and then all that stuff and
then so i think the
give me a [ __ ] break part is for that
where it's like
she's doing the stuff that she's
supposed to but they're not
airing it in liberal media is what she's
saying she's like it's not fair that i'm
actually doing this [ __ ]
and then you're coming at me and asking
me why am i yeah and then
if he goes we give him the material they
don't want to [ __ ] air it so i was
like
well i was under the impression that
she's not doing anything she's just
being pretty model wife
and she's doing stupid [ __ ] and making
copying speeches
that's what i thought she was but if her
husband bombed assad tomorrow the media
would be coming all over him
and that's what that's where i'm like i
don't know what's going on
but there's a corporatist thing going on
with the war
media and the elites who own our press
with five companies who own our press
and it's all tied together so all the
generals we have the joint chiefs
when they leave those posts they go work
for defense contractors it's a circular
[ __ ]
firing squad of [ __ ] for the rest of
[Music]
us
foreign